si les commerçants s'alarme des pertes
de chiffre d'affaires lié à la crise
dite des gilet jaune après les
opérations de filtrage au niveau des
ronds points force est de constater que
les consommateurs ont aussi adapter
leurs comportements d'achat
ça les a modifié où ils n'ont pas ce
qu'en font ça on s'adapte en fonction de
ce qui se passe actuellement mais après
le samedi oui un peu plus on évite de se
déplacer le samedi parvenir le samedi et
puis bon bah la semaine c'est plus cool
et puis bah voilà mais j'habite à
meung-sur-loire mais c'est pas mieux
ben moi je viens plus le week-end voilà
c'est tout sinon en passant par derrière
on n'est pas gêné par les juges
eh bien j'ai vite et les week-ends et
puis sinon je vais aux horaires comme là
où il ya personne et voilà on est
tranquille et j'ai pas eu de problème
pour mes courses
vous avez rencontré des jeunes à moment
où je faisais des courses
oui au rond-point de gérando une fois
mais bon ça pas été si tu es bon enfant
et sa pas été méchant du tout comme ça
ces filtres en prendre notre patience
puis c'est tout en évitant le week-end
ou le soir après le bureau les acheteurs
se sont adaptés aux difficultés de
circulation même maintenant que les
ronds points sont inoccupés le climat
anxiogène continue à freiner la reprise
de la consommation